a couple of weeks ago I brought you the
story of a new Pew Religion Center study
which showed that none no religious
affiliation is the fastest-growing
choice for respondents in pews annual
religion survey and I made clear at the
time that when someone says none as
their religious affiliation that doesn't
necessarily mean that they are atheist
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
don't believe in a God although it may
what it really tells us is they don't
affiliate with an organized religion and
that can be good that can be bad
I wasn't presenting it at the time as a
sort of value judgment or value
statement it was simply to tell you that
the evidence indicates that people are
moving away from organized religion some
portion of them are atheists or
non-believers of different stripes but
the point was that the role of organized
religion is diminishing in American
society and after we did that story I
started thinking about the ways in which
religion is sort of being defeated and I
use that word again I'm not trying to
use it in a sort of I'm using it in a
value neutral way and it's not that
religion is sort of being defeated in
maude the modern West because churches
are losing followers although that's
happening it's not just that organized
religion is losing adherents although
that's also happening and it's not even
necessarily about people no longer
literally believing religious teachings
or no longer believing in a God also
although that also is happening it's not
even really about secularism the
separation of church and state although
we are working to make that a reality we
want separation of church and state what
I what I sort of realized was the way in
which we can see that religion is in a
downfall is that none of the big ideas
are coming from religion anymore no will
they I would argue think back for a
second when you think back to math
during the Golden Age of Islam for
example or the development of science
within the Catholic Church there's a
really good argument to be made that
these advancements
didn't come from the religion but they
came during a time when most people were
religiously affiliated so sort of like
by definition advancements were at least
nominally tied to those religions you
don't even have to debate that at this
point if you imagine the big inventions
of the 21st century whatever you think
they're going to be or imagine humanity
five hundred years from now or a
thousand years from now are the most
important or the most relevant
advancements and discoveries from humans
going to come from religion can we make
that case at all I don't think that we
can like what is the Catholic Church
doing in 2018
that is monumental for Humanity right
now what elements of 25th century humans
will be impacted by the research and
teachings of Orthodox Jews in 2018 in
what way is Islam today going to push
the ball forward for homo sapiens in the
next hundred years or 200 years we won't
know for some time but the real way I
would argue that religion has been
pushed aside in the West is that it's
simply no longer part of what's shaping
the future of humanity and you know
religious belief it could grow it could
fall it impacts humanity whether people
go to church influences people's daily
lives but religion is basically no
longer playing a role in figuring out
the major issues facing homo sapiens
climate change religion is not playing a
role in figuring out climate change
moving beyond humans as merely being on
earth moving to a multiplanetary species
religion is not playing a role in that
other than trying to maybe restrict it
dealing with the current coming
technological revolution the development
of artificial intelligence how that's
going to impact the relationships of
humans to work into the economy religion
has things to say about it
but do we think that in 300 years
religion will have figured out any of
those issues I
don't know how anyone can make that case
and that's how I believe religion is
going to fade in terms of its influence
in determining the future of humanity
and it's really important Pat for me to
point out this isn't an attack on
religion right
I have views on religious belief I've
espoused them we can talk about the
impact of religious belief on crime or
on the economy or whatever you want to
talk about I'm not making a value
judgment what I'm saying is that at this
point what is shaping the future of
humanity what is going to answer the big
questions in the next 50 hundred however
many years is not going to come from
religion and I would hope that that
people don't see that as an offensive
thing if they disagree let me know why
you disagree well I think if anything
religions going to stifle scientific and
medical advancements because when we
talk about the way of the future things
like Chris Pirelli gene editing
techniques or we talk about stem cell
research or we talk about vaccines like
the people that are against all of those
sorts of programs not all of them but
many of them tend to be part of the
religious community they disagree with
it on a religious basis and that stuff
that's that position that viewpoint is
holding us back on all those things yes
so you're actually going further you're
actually saying it's not that religion
will be a non-factor in what is most
important for humans in the next however
many years you're actually saying that
it may be a limiting influence and I
don't disagree with that although it was
not you don't need to debate that merely
to recognize that that is really a way
in which religion has been pushed aside
am I wrong do you disagree if so I want
to hear from you I want to hear from you
if you believe that religion is still
going to over the next hundred years 200
years be part of the big discoveries the
big advancements that impact the daily
lives of humans of Homo sapiens then I
want to hear from you I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
quick break we've got a great Friday
show for you today
today's program sponsored in part by
blinkers comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree I know I'm not able to read all
of the books that I want simply because
I've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like blinka stand i think you are
going to like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n